hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute habe ich ein richtig
leckeres rezept für euch denn ich mache
eine philadelphia torte
ich finde so eine torte ist genau das
richtige für warme sommertage
denn ich habe sie noch etwas
aufgehübscht mit ein paar limetten und
ein paar erdbeeren und das wird noch
richtig lockere leichte creme mit einem
schönen wickelt eick ich zeige euch auch
gleich wie das funktioniert
ich zeige ich jetzt erstmal alle zutaten
das sieht auf den ersten schlager
zuletzt ein bisschen viel aus aber im
prinzip sind es ganz viele grundzutaten
und dann hat noch ein paar früchte und
ja wissen was für die gräben und die
samira macht hier kurz neben mir und ich
zeige ich jetzt erstmal die zutaten für
die bittet orten
wir brauchen dafür 325 gramm zucker 100
gramm mineralwasser also sprudel 60
gramm öl 150 gramm mehl und ein halbes
päckchen backpulver dann brauche ich
noch eine limette für den teig und zwar
nehme ich davon die schale
hier zeige ich euch die zutaten für den
brösel boden
ich habe hier 100 gramm pixar das
netzwerk an kekse 100 g gehackte mandeln
ich brauche dafür zwei esslöffel zucker
und 125 gramm butter und dann nur noch
die zutaten für die creme und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier bereits 400 milliliter
schlagsahne
ich brauche 800 gramm frischkäse dann
nehme ich ganz gern philadelphia und ich
habe hier 200 gramm puderzucker und
natürlich app werden und noch mehr
limetten einfach für die creme und für
den teig und ich habe ich mir bereits in
wagram und zurechtgelegt hat es bei mir
so ungefähr 32 x 35 cm
ihr könnt aber auch ein ganz normales
backblech benutzen ich packe es nur ganz
gern so war das schon richtig
jetzt starte ich einfach direkt mit dem
rührteig als mit dem wickeltisch die
eier geben weil es in eine rührschüssel
rein
dann kommt da der zucker mit dazu
und dann wird das ganze einfach schön
cremig verrührt
jetzt geben wir hier noch die
limettenschale mit rein die haben wir
bereits abgeschrieben
abgelehnt hat die sanierer machen dürfen
kommt noch öl und das wasser mit rein
und das hören wir jetzt bei ganz
niedriger stufe ganz kurz ein
ich führe jetzt hier schon mal
backpulver mit dem mehl während dieser
mir schon mal die zweite limettenschale
abtreibt wird die creme und für den
anderen teil
das liebe ich hier kurz rein und es
fröhlich jetzt auch bei niedriger stufe
ganz kurz runter
jetzt gebe ich den fertigen teig einfach
in die vorbereitete backform da geht
auch wirklich sehr schnell
das müsst ihr einfach so ein bisserl
drin verteile
und so wird der teig jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 175 grad etwa
ober und unterhitze für etwa neun
minuten gebacken
danach nämlich in rauslassen komplett
abkühlen und die zwischenzeit nutze ich
um schon mal den brüssel bodengleich
herzustellen
und wenn ihr für meine torte auf der
philadelphia seite abstimmt dann könnt
ihr nämlich auch was gewinnen
wenn nämlich meine torte gewinnt und für
mich abgestimmt hat dann verlosen rewe
und philadelphia zwei küchenmaschine und
war einmal dieser kitchenaid artist
mitteilte arbeite und einmal wie hier im
hintergrund den blauen mixa ich weiß es
natürlich nicht die farbe aber das ist
das was ihr gewinnen könnt und da habt
ihr eben auch was davon
ich nehme es einfach die kekse diese
vollkornkekse und samira darf sie dann
mit nudelholz gleich zerkleinern
einfach hier in den beutel rein macht
das matte rein und ich kann ihn derzeit
schon mal meine mandeln in einer pfanne
etwas anrösten und die werde ich gleich
noch karamellisieren einfach für den
leckeren geschmack genau alle da rein in
den weiteren kleinen tipp gebe ich die
butter die kann ich darin schon mal
verlassen
jetzt zu machen damit nichts haus
spritzt ok und dann einfach drüber
rollen super kannst du auch so ein
bisserl klappt rücken aber nicht so laut
dass die nachbarn schimpfen okay
und wenn die mandeln dann etwas
angeröstet sind das erkennt man einfach
am geruch winds in der küche richtig
schön duftet dann gebe ich noch den
zucker mit rein dann darf das ganze
nämlich noch ein bisschen
karamellisieren
und so kriegen wir einfach so ein
bisschen krank mit den die torte rein
ich mache das ganz gerne wenn man in so
einem brösel boden auch so ein bisschen
was knackiges hat und das sorge neben
die karamellisiertem mandeln dann dafür
und wenn die mandeln dann schön
goldbraun sind lebt sie mit zu den
keksen da müssen jetzt aufpassen die
mantel sind natürlich ganz ganz heiß
da kommt dann auch gleich die flüssige
butter mit rein das siehst du wie heißt
es ist und das verriet jetzt schön
miteinander auf keinen fall mit den
händen immer mit einem löffel weil es
ist wirklich sehr heiß
und du darfst noch ein paar
limettenschale mit reinen geben einfach
so mit der hand damit es eben auch
richtig gut schmeckt sagt es reicht
schon
also noch mal die schale von einer
limette und habe ich mir jetzt bereits
eine form zurechtgelegt und zwar einfach
so ein schild tortenplatte mit einem
roten rahmen außen rum
den habe ich auf 24 cm durchmesser
eingestellt und fülle hier jetzt diesen
brösel boden ein und muss den
gleichaltrigen flach drücken sie auf
keinen fall mit den händen das ist zu
heiß so zuerst verteidigt es schön hier
mit dem teig schaber und dann nehme ich
mir einfach ein glas zu hilfe und drückt
den boden schön flach so bleibt das
schön zusammen und wir haben eine
richtig schöne kruste unten trend
und während der andere teil jetzt noch
im ofen backen kann ich den brösel boden
auch nummer kalt stellen und dann sehen
wir uns gleich wieder wenn ich die creme
zubereitet
unsere beiden tortenböden sind jetzt
karls den brösel boden habe ich noch im
kühlschrank der andere liegt jetzt
bereits hier den hatte ich nämlich schön
abgedeckt und während die samir reiche
jetzt noch die erdbahn schneidet das
macht jetzt mit seinem eierschneider
zeigt mal wie du es machst einfach wäre
ich hab das grün schon ab jetzt legt sie
rein und so genau und dann einfach
darüber gar okay das schaffst du schon
und während dieser mir hat es hier noch
macht kann ich schon mal die krähen
vorbereiten und schlagt dafür erst mal
die sahne steif und damit die torte
später auch schön fest bleibt gebe ich
da einfach gleich noch zwei teelöffel
vor meinem sahnesteif mittel betreiben
jetzt ist die sahne steigt jetzt kann
ich noch den frischkäse verrühren mit
dem bruder kuppe
jetzt geben wir hier noch den
puderzucker mit dazu und ich press schon
mal den saft von zwei limetten mit rein
macht die creme nämlich auch richtig
schön fruchtig und frisch
ich helfe dir bis mittelgroße händler
jetzt kommt da noch die restlichen
limetten schalen mit rein
es ist auch ganz kurz verrühren
jetzt können wir hier noch die sahne
unterheben
die creme ist auch schon fertig und
jetzt kann ich den tortenboden
zurechtschneiden und zwar habe ich hier
ein lineal dafür und schneidet jetzt den
tortenboden so in 5 cm breite streifen
und dann kann man nämlich später schön
aufwickeln
gerade einmal mit messer und am teig
durch saugen backpapier entlang dann
löst sich nämlich das backpapier vom
teig und klebt dann einfach nicht mehr
so jetzt kommt der schöne teil jetzt
streichen wir nämlich die creme etwa so
zwei drittel davon auf den tortenboden
auch nicht zu viel denn wir brauchen
noch ein bisschen cremen später für die
verzierung
gerade einmal noch mehr messer über
diese schnittstelle dann sieht die sache
nämlich gleich wo sie die erdbahn eben
drauf legen darf nämlich hier so etwas
überlegen
jetzt lese ich hier den torten rand von
dem brüssel boden einfach damit ich
besser arbeiten kann
ich brauche aber gleich wieder und jetzt
kommt der spaß geteilt jetzt rollt ihr
nämlich die erste tour von diesem
biscuit auf deswegen heißt das ganze
auch wickel kuchen salzstock sei nur der
erste da kommt jetzt hier in die mitte
wird einfach mit rein gestellt und die
restlichen die muss ich jetzt wie so
eine schnecke außenrum wickelt muss man
vorsichtig sein was er eben auch noch
dreist wenn es euch zu lange stand
könnte das auch in kleinere stücke
schneiden und einfach kleiner wickeln
dann stelle ich hier den torten rahmen
wieder außen ruf und ziehen wieder fest
dann hat die torte nämlich so die
perfekte form und einfach auch diesen
halt damit sie gleich so kalt werden
kann
einfach schön festziehen
jetzt könnt ihr mit der restlichen creme
erst mal so ein paar lücken noch
ausfüllen für mich damit der teig auch
bis zum rand geht
ich koche sie dich ganz
die oberseite streichen glatt
und bevor ich den jetzt fertig
dekorieren kann stelle ich ihn erst mal
für etwa eine halbe stunde kalt dann ist
das schön facebook r ihn gleich fertig
stellen
die torte ist schön abgekühlt und jetzt
lese ich einmal den torten rahmen
und dann nehme ich jetzt die restliche
creme und streicht damit die komplette
heute ein sowohl als sowohl oben als
auch abbrand
ich habe jetzt die torte fertig glatt
gestrichen und jetzt dekore ich sie
einfach mit den erdbeeren und mit ein
paar limetten scheiben aus
meine tochter weiß noch mal in der
kühlung als er im kühlschrank und jetzt
kann ich sehr anschneiden euch mal diese
wickel optik zeigen
auf jeden fall müsste einmal ganz gut
durchschneiden denn ich habe diesen
festen größen boden darunter
und jetzt sieht man hier ganz deutlich
dass einfach diese torte einfach mal
anders aussieht normalerweise hat man
die zarten blüten immer so ein bisserl
waagerecht jetzt stehen sie hier
senkrecht und vor allem habt ihr jetzt
im boden diesen schönen crunch drin mit
diesen karamellisiertem mandeln dann
diesen richtig lockeren biskuitteig mit
dem erdbeeren und der leckeren
philadelphia creme und ich finde die
einfach super lecker weil sie halt diese
limettenschale mit drin hat den
limettensaft mit trainer hat dann noch
die erdbeeren also für mich ist diese
torte einfach sommer pur und solltet ihr
auf jeden fall mal nachmachen und das
rezept könnt ihr natürlich nachlesen auf
salehs - blog.de und ich würd mich jetzt
natürlich freuen wenn er bei der torte
für mich abstimmen würde und einfach für
meine torte wartet ich schreibe euch die
genauen details und den link zum boten
einfach nochmal direkt unter das video
in die video beschreibung in diese info
box mit rein
natürlich gibt es auch andere torten
wenn euch die besser gefallen wurde die
reben für die anderen aber ich würde
mich natürlich sehr freuen wenn meine
zuschauer für mich wurden
und ja ich finde das ist eine richtig
coole sommerliche party torte auch eine
gartenpforte und ja ich freue mich wenn
ihr den nach macht und wünsche euch ganz
viel spaß dabei ich lass mir dir
schmecken mit der familie
bis bald